Hi!  I'm Anna Akana, and I have 4 cats.
And they're going to review costumes!
They're probably going to hate it.  But it's going to be sups-(super) adorbs!
All right, so I'm going to put Congress in this Pikachu outfit and see how he likes it!
I'll put it here.  (Talking to Congress)  And, okay--good!
I'll roll you over.
Congo!  Do you like it?  Do you enjoy it?
(Giggling)
Oh God.
Oh!  Oh! *gasps*
Oh GOD!
*Window shattering sound* Slo-Mo "OH GOD!"
Honey!  Oh God.  Oh God.
Ok!  This is cute but not safe.
Did you see him fall?
Brad:  (off camera) Mhmm!
No!  I don't want to show that--that's so sad!
Ok so he had a lot of trouble with that, so I'm not going to put him back in this.  Anytime soon.
Maybe never.
We got...Lillian a Kimino!
She feels sensual.  *giggling*
Lilly is wearing a Kimono because she is sophisticated and the oldest of the cats.
She hates it, I think, but will tolerate it because she's pretty chill.
All right, Congress has a lot of trouble with Pikachu so lets see if he enjoys being a spider!
No? He's already ready to walk away.  He has had enough.
*Laughing*
He looks like a super hero!
*tsk tsk tsk* (Cat calling noises)
Yea you deserve it!  You deserve it!  You fell.
You fell for our Youtube video.
Abby spider cat now!  Oh!  There she goes!
Spider cat!  (tune of original Spider Man song)
*In The Hall of The Mountain King Plays*
She's actually a spider crawling up!
So Jimmy has noticed everyone in costumes and has run away each time I've tried to grab him.
I got him a tuxedo, because he's a fancy boy!
(To Jimmy) Here we go!  Oh, you're ready to get married!
Here you go!  Stand at the altar.
To greet your bride!
Oh my God look at that GQ!  GQ!  Yasss (yes) work it Jimmy! Yasss work it!  You look so handsome!
I think this is a sign that he's next.  I'm going to have Grandchildren soon.
*gasps* Why are you hiding?!
Where are you going? *velcro being undone* This is in preparation for Halloween!
Be the bird!  *sighs* what a Diva!  Is this what having children is like?
*Old time Saloon music playing*
Hah!
*Giggling*
He's just backing up.  "How do I get out of this!?"
Oh my God!
She doesn't like it, but she's tolerating it because she's nice.
So many of these costumes are too small...except for Congress.
Oh!  You are a fan favorite today!  Oh!
Roar!
This costume was even too small for Congo.  So I don't know exactly what kind of tiny animal is supposed to fit this.
What do you think is going on through his head?
Uh, I can't even begin to fathom what Congress is thinking.
He's probably just uncomfortable and afraid to move.  Either that he's just thinking about life and whether or not he could potentially actually be a dinosaur.
This!  I really want to get Jim in.
Jim only did one costume and I want to get him in more.
Oh he's taking a shit.  Haha.
He's in the litter box!  Get him in the litter box!
*humming melody*
*Laughing*
It looks like a Varsity Jacket for a cat because it's a fish!
(To Jimmy) Well you can pull it off on your own, you know you can.  Go ahead.
I'm afraid he's going to get Crazy Town
Well he's mad!
(Jimmy) *low grumbling*
See?  Gosh!
I saw this pirate costume on a cat online, and I was like "I must have this!" But this is like, tiny!
Like I can--my finger--and it's got elastic but it's like damn!  They should make this a little bigger.  You know cats are fat--so what are you doing?!
Oh my God!  He looks so cute!  The illusion of him walking is so funny!
Walk a little bit!  Go ahead!
I've got one last costume left!  In a human.
No!  That's it!
That's all!  They don't like it.  I thought they'd like this one because it's not like you're in a costume.  You're just in my belly.
Here!
Now this is my version of pregnancy.  Just a whole litter of kittens popping out of here!
She likes it!  I like this costume.  It keeps them close.
So that kind of went exactly how I thought it would go--lots of anger all around--but they looked adorable.
I wish more of the costumes were bigger.  We could only fit Congress into a bunch of them--and even then some of them were too small.
But anyway!  I have been really enjoying this.  Let me know what my cats should review next!
And if you dress up your animals, what kind of costumes have you done?  Have you found any success?
Or do cats just freeze all the time instantly?
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.